Ben Wyatt from the state budget office
yeah how's it going hello thanks for the
party good pizza great
so yeah pizza's dynamite isn't it you
said it was a good picture
good pizzas good do you uh you know what
I like
calzones that was wrong with this guy
sorry we'll check in with you later
take it easy yeah great small talk over
there okay hey hey hey hey hey Ronny
listen you're just who I was looking for
are you did you forget the did you
connect can I get that thing can we just
uh did you bring it this isn't good
Vincent yeah how can you justify raising
taxes for something they'll hurt the
town I would just add to what Ben's
stammering about we aren't going to
raise taxes so that's that next caller
thank you
I really needed bit even Ben's dancing
we need the Pawnee police force to
volunteer as security during the
upcoming harvest festival now the city
won't let us throw the festival and
what's more just send me a schedule of
how many officers you need and win
really just like that Leslie Knope gets
as many favors issue needs can ask why
because she's the kind of a person who
uses favors to help other people and
also my buddy dave was the Frankie's
bastard in the department until he
started dating listening huh so she okay
are they still dating or no where does
San Diego a year ago was it a serious
thing or what do you care you pervert
nope nope I'm all good um everything's
fine this is fine sorry sorry I scare
you know a lot of cars I mean not too
many trucks stuff but you know cool good
talk ice town okay why do they want to
destroy it well it's a painting of me as
a centaur okay and it's a nude oh just
basically like the chestal region uh-huh
mostly you don't have to look at it if
you don't want to no no no it's very
classy yeah no I'm sure do mm-hmm that's
Chris take this okay hi Chris Leslie
Knope you need to bring that painting
back what painting Leslie you have the
painting and you need to bring it back
in I think I've been pretty fair with
you and I'm starting to feel angry okay
I'm sorry if I could just explain to you
my point of view you will bring up
painting in tomorrow morning and
surrender it to Marcia Langman that's
that do you understand me madam welcome
to you heard with perd i'm perd hapley
the story of our guest today is that
they're from the Department of Park
some recreation Ben Wyatt and Tom
Haverford what up hurt
big fan me - perd what up the thing
about this first question is I'd like to
ask you about the harvest festival bird
it's gonna be amazing
carnival rides games Sweden is even
building a plus-size roller coaster for
some Aponte's obese drill seekers
you must be this wide to ride well oh
that's gonna be a pretty big roller
coaster yep hey guys
calzones are pointless they're just
pizza that's harder to eat no one likes
them good day sir
you know I'm just kidding let's go oh
okay that's a bit trouble there thanks a
lot bro stop sorry I was a kid and when
you you you you end up getting out there
and and there's a I really wish you guys
could see this guy right now he is
drantch in sweat there's also gonna be
ponies at the Harvest Festival alright
let's take a caller from douche nation
all right talk to me caller soap guys
just do [__] over here in Eagleton sweet
seems like 18 is pretty young for a
mayor what were you like 12 the funny um
when I guess the fortunate
can we just sort of game over man or we
could go out after work you know go to
JJ's or something grab a bite um I don't
think I can but why don't we just talk
about later in this building okay all
right but uh you're great and you have
great ideas and but if I thought you
were serious I'd be offended bird but I
know that we're buddies I know you
wouldn't do that to me but you know this
is a birthmark perd okay this is the
little scar I got when I was nine and I
fell off my bike so no I'm not perfect I
can't look away
it's um it's amazing okay no here's the
best part okay that's all the time we
have here on you heard i'm perd hapley
channel for more like turd crap li yeah
[Applause]
look who hasn't had gay thoughts who you
okay yeah I'm fine
finds mean you know sometimes I feel
like it might need glasses is there a
bird in here I swear I keep seeing a
bird in the studio kind of this happens
do it he was fine until perch started
asking about the boy mayor stuff
what's wrong with you you look psychotic
I was 18 when I was elected mayor okay
so excuse me for that cindy eckert had
just turned me down for senior prom do
you know how that feel i should call her
I should know I shouldn't and I'm not
going to and I'm proud of myself
[Music]
well I am very glad you came back up
here oh yeah me too yeah sorry you got a
deal
well let me Mull everything over and
then we can reconnect and hash things
out it might get rough but that can be
fun Ben can handle it okay great it was
mm-hmm
what's so great if she was impressed by
you too I mean you could tell instantly
the way good for connecting is really
amazing now what I'm thinking is that
maybe we should go over to her house
cheap trample nice to see you hi hey
nope right been a long time a captain or
captain Oh captain my captain
from Dead Poets Society you're getting
weird already nope I'm good pawnees
police chief is retiring and I'm trying
to get his endorsement before he goes
I'm really nervous because I need this
for my campaign and Ben is really
nervous because he is afraid of cops I'm
not afraid of cops have no reason to be
I never break any laws ever because I'm
deathly afraid of cops look nope I've
always liked you but the Newports run
this town and frankly they've donated a
lot of money to the department Mo Money
mo problems that's what I always say how
about Mo Money more protected Kevlar
vests that save lives I sometimes I say
that too I understand you need to think
about it but if you were gonna make a
decision guys are throwing me a little
retirement thing tonight at o'flanagan's
it's gonna be beer so once you swing by
I'll give you an answer where dough can
come to all right let's go
oh hey may I say the boys in blue are
heroes obviously some more than others
my boy here comes 9/11 animal walk okay
he's in love with you and he has a guy
can you just not freak out I'm not
freaking out I'm not for you uh I know
that's I know I shouldn't have invited
him I'm sorry no no no that's okay
Hey want a beer oh okay if you're
driving I can't give you a beer oh well
then no thank you
it's a celebration and you have to have
a drink I'll definitely have one don't
make a mistake you'll always regret
please just tell me what you want me to
do tonight he's going to endorse ben and
trumple is going to endorse me double
endorsement ooh that sounds like an
Ashley Judd movie I'm reaching for paper
oh good oh hey Dave go ahead you're
waiting no no I'm not you're not wait no
it feels like you're feels to me like
you you're being overly respectful of
all these cops and you're and you're
letting them go in all in front no no no
I'm just standing here why would you be
standing just here I gave him a go in
thank you so much
[Music]